[Musique]
le coronavirus
ce que sur le toit du monde à plus de
5300 mètres d'altitude le camp de base
de l'everest a vu ces derniers jours au
moins 35 personnes contaminées être
rapatriés vers la capitale népalaise
when your heart on se promène dans le
camp de base on peut entendre dans
certaines tentes les gens tousser ils
sont malades ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
face à l'épidémie qui progresse grimpeur
et sherpa respectent désormais des
mesures barrières en pleine montagne à
l'entrée des tentes des panneaux
interdit d'entrée ont été installés les
groupes d'expédition ne se mélangent
plus les uns les autres
même si nous ne pouvons pas faire de
procession à travers les rues de bruges
aujourd'hui le christ nous accompagnent
réellement sur nos routes
il accompagne les médecins et les
infirmières qui se rendent auprès des
manades j'ai bien est-ce que la soirée
dansante dans un lieu privé peut se
poursuivre au delà de 23 heures
alors oui elle peut se poursuivre mais
la question c'est que voilà il va
falloir qu'elle se poursuive jusqu'à 6
heures du matin parce que une fois une
fois que le couvre-feu est entamée et
bien les convives devront rester sur
place ils ne pourront pas quitter cette
salle
donc soit ils dorment sur place soit il
continue à faire la fête et on compte
sur vous jusqu'à 6 heures du matin qui
convaincra pas les armes pour être
doublé donc ça qu'on n'est pas obligé de
danser jusqu'à 6 on peut s'arrêter à 2h
ou 3h et jean macé dormir lors d'une
cérémonie d'une fête de mariage qu'on
est bien fatigué en pesant bien sûr une
enceinte c'est soit contrée ouais il ya
des anecdotes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez un rêve si vous
gagnez beaucoup de souche est donc pour
l'instant d'une 300 euros il pourrait
vous servir à quoi c'est je peux pas le
dire ici je pense c'est vrai à castres
et mon chien à castres et votre chien
vous sortez toujours des trucs que je
sais pas d'où ça sort tout
[Rires]
mais qu'est ce qui t'a pris je pense que
je voulais faire une fleur à la base
mais j'ai mélangé de délire si tu aimes
les caps tu sais tu n es bistouquette
battu fait la fusion et tu fais une
piste où que tu sois pas là parfait
roman de la chine tu vas faire laisse
racisme à bb
moi qui est terrible pour le poids de
tous les français c'est chaque année le
mois de janvier
vous voyez les plus grosses bas c'est à
peu près 300 g prix en moyenne par
l'état elle est faite juste avant la rue
ce n'est pas exactement c'est l'effet
des fêtes et alors ce qui est amusant
c'est que oui il ya eu un petit effet
confinement sans doute soon sur notre
poids parce qu'on a moins marché mais
surtout encore plus que les autres
années on s'est rattrapés peut-être
parce qu'on était déprimé sur la dinde
le foie gras le chocolat et on a appris
plus de poids aux noëls 2020 que
d'habitude ça va déborder sa toile
c'était bien c'est bien sûr faux
tableaux y est enfin est ce que c'est
que d'avoir fait sciences po mais oui
tiens à ce propos répétés de pouce mais
je suis passé devant j'ai fait devant
sur smooth à rien
cette femme qui a fait cette demande je
voudrais que vous veniez demain matin à
5h30 pour constater un tapage mon voisin
du dessus à dire la chasse d'eau
l'opératrice lui a répondu qu'il n'y
avait rien d'anormal mais elle a insisté
à 6,6 et insupportable parce qu'en plus
ils ne travaillent pas assez c'est comme
ça c'est des sages est vrai ce n'est pas
une blague
écoutez un auditeur qui s'adresse à moi
en fait pour parler d'al azhar et salut
c'est pour devenir un joueur a alors dit
lui qui s'offre à embêter par julien
courbet il a le droit de boire un canon
comme tout le monde
positive attitude positive attitude
positive attitude tout à dos toute la
semaine ça touchera père
ça c'est la job à 15 mais la bataille a
sonné j'ai présenté le métier ou de fr3
part il de son ancêtre il ya 30 ans
c'est très précis mais c'était
improbable et je n'avais comme météo
france ne me donnait pas les bulletins
météo cervin vantait les températures et
les précipitations n'ont et comme
j'étais jeune et que j'étais content je
faisais toujours pleuvoir sur les
yvelines
pas moi vu le nombre de courriers qu'on
recevait plaindre que je ne comprends
pas vous fait pleuvoir tous les jours
alors qu'il fait un temps superbe on m'a
tapé sur les doigts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
adia rien et valesco direction la
piscine
ici c'est marseille mais neuf
[Applaudissements]
ça sonne et frais
[Musique]
ça sonne à la porte et en fait je sais
très bien que c'est mme ne va pas venir
mais j'ai une petite lueur d'espoir que
ce soit lui qui vient de me rendre
visite donc du coup je cours en bombe